[Musique]
maurice genevoix tels que vous ne l'avez
sans doute jamais vu
imaginé par des peintres et des
sculpteurs du loiret avec leurs pattes
leur style ils ont représenté l'écrivain
académicien et prix goncourt en 1925
j'ai voulu montrer un maurice genevoix
dans la plénitude de son âge avec la
suggestion de ses habits d'académicien
mais surtout ce que j'ai voulu
représenter c'était la vie intérieure de
vauré genevois qui était très riche au
travers de trois autoportrait et
notamment ceux de 14 donc cette scène de
guerre voilà avec ses soldats la grande
harde avec le cerf rouge et puis
raboliot dans sa forêt
le cerveau
ces artistes n'ont pas forcément
rencontré maurice genevoix il connaît
son oeuvre savent qu'il a vécu et
travaillé ici dans le loiret
l'artiste peintre bulle des roulettes la
représenter à sa façon tout en couleurs
c'était quelqu'un qui aimait vraiment la
loi d'un amoureux de la loi et moi aussi
je prends beaucoup j'adore aller me
balader en bord de loire donc j'ai
imaginé que j'avais maurice en face de
moi que je lui
donné ma carte de visite
voilà ça fait un peu partie d'une série
que j'ai faits qui s'appelle qui
s'appelle fantasmes où je donne une
carte de visite à des gens décédés que
j'aurais aimé rencontrer avec tous ces
portraits les artistes rendent hommage à
celui qui a créé il y a un siècle
l'association des artistes aurélia elle
allait donner une vraie dimension à son
amour de l'art et ce goût pour la
peinture qu'il a depuis son enfance
puisque c'était sa deuxième vocation il
aurait pu être peintre et aussi ce goût
de l'amitié parce qu'il avait énormément
d'amis artistes et peintres après le
cauchemar de la première guerre mondiale
s'occuper des artistes a permis à
maurice genevoix de reprendre pied dans
la vie
[Musique]